what's the deal with airplane peanuts
very don't harden the paint huh i like
her all right hey
hey hey you out of ten i need you daddy
doesn't it daddy doesn't watch
porn what you seem a little pent up
i never watch porn wow and i haven't
watched porn in many years
yeah i like a good idea but i like her i
do it every day and it's got to be black
yeah but i don't know how do you how do
you do it what are you imagination like
eighth grade style uh i
i i'm older i just i don't know yeah i
don't think back to uh
i don't even know jack off in black and
white i don't know
anymore really i swear to god what i'm
just you know what dude get the [ __ ] out
yeah
i know you're talking like how you're
sitting
he's better than him he's growing up
they had a thing for a while girls
uh lsd in their vagina yeah
and go hard a dick trip your dick will
go in and get all burning man
that was the thing yeah whoa the girl
was tripping then you get in there and
get some of the trip and so it was just
real i don't mind a trip but i don't
want it through my dick hole
that's that's a weird surprise that's a
way it's a while
big knicks a creeper well he's a
premature baby dude so he's making up
for lost
oh were you a preemie well you came out
good that's what i'm saying man
why a lot of these guys going 36 and
nick got out early bro nick is a hard
worker
oh yeah i was like a c-sec really oh
yeah i came out through the [ __ ]
roof oh wow or i guess maybe the moon
roof or something
i didn't come out through the door i
could see you being like i don't know
you know is this the best thoroughfare
right let me see what else is going on
and
you've all touched your mom's vag i
haven't touched well maybe you've
touched my mom's she's a big [ __ ]
but uh i haven't touched my mom's vagina
which feels pretty good oh yeah
oh that i guess i could see that yeah
there is always a weird element i think
sometimes when i look at my mom and she
and i both know what i did yeah yeah you
ruined her labia
yeah for a while they say it goes back
yeah i hear it's never exactly the same
but that's my buddy said that
oh well maybe he had a big kid or
something
yeah he said though because i've we've
all banged some milfs and it didn't feel
that different
yeah i don't have any feelings in my
penis at all i don't feel like oh really
come on i don't think so i mean all so
many of the nerves are in my brain that
it's so
it's like if i think hard enough i can
feel something but otherwise it's kind
of like uh
wait are you serious yeah i'm just not i
mean yeah like
you're not very sensitive downtown i
don't think so i don't know what
you're not [ __ ] all over no no really
oh i put it in i'm done oh man yeah i
mean don't worry i got the brain stuff
too i'm going i hate myself
i'm tiny i'm gay all this [ __ ] yeah i
don't have the uh oh you got the band
back together huh
oh yeah oh yeah my dick's like uh like a
girl at seeing the notebook
it's just weeping it's bad
bro the first time i ever had sex i
remember getting right up like
literally my penis was right outside of
this girl's um
vagina yes and it just like sneezed
ejaculate you know just like
like it was so nervous yeah yeah so it
hit the out so
it pressure washed oh definitely and it
was like uh it was almost like my venus
was like i'm too sick to handle this and
just
vomited outside of this girl's entryway
you puked at the table you didn't even
get to the buffet
oh man you golden corral and we were so
ready everybody was so ready
so then i had to pretend like i was so
ready bro and that was crazy because i
had to like
oh hold on i don't want to just do this
yeah make up this long story
right all the europe ones you know you
get loose in amsterdam
we got loose we you know we just did the
canals and get a got a bunch of weeds
are you a drug guy
no not a weed guy i can't do it i'm too
[ __ ] up
the weed brings out all the demons yeah
it doesn't suppress them like alcohol
you have your darkness it's from your
childhood i think so you had a weird
childhood how so
well let's see uh my dad got a wild hair
up his ass and bought a mansion
dilapidated mansion in a poor black
neighborhood
so first of all the house was [ __ ] we
barely had running water it was you know
we'd have
family meetings all right go [ __ ] at
school don't [ __ ] here we need the water
and then my dad started running out of
money so
he made the back half of bed and
breakfast like old style bit so my mom's
whipping up pancakes at eight a.m and
i'm like can i get one she's like blow
me dick
uh eat eat a bowl of cheerios you [ __ ]
and so i was like all right sorry jesus
and so you and you know they're so my
peers are workaholics they're checked
out you know
they they were nice people but they're
just like hey we gave birth to you
you figured it out yeah go watch tv
there's no attention
yes dr drew i just think that happened
to a [ __ ] comment maybe but boy it's
sad don't give them attention
so what doctor do you say so he said
you're uh because i was like my mom
didn't react like i have girlfriends all
introduced to my mom they're like
that was tough i felt like i was bombing
in there i'm like welcome to my life you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
jesus christ 20 years of that [ __ ]
growing up
and uh so i wonder you need
the last from [ __ ] strange exactly
like ask me a question just ask me a
random question
uh my mom um a random question um
where are you from
what time is it where are we you know
it's just like oh [ __ ] sorry
gage yeah and it's she's not mean she's
just like she's just got her checked out
yeah she's just like thinking about all
right i got to pay the bill i got to
water the plants you know and you're
like you have brothers and sisters
older brother he's a genius he's like
this you know math
computer wizard and our neighborhood was
so dangerous that he just
head into a computer like as a kid and
he just became like
dos and [ __ ] did you make friends in the
neighborhood with the black yeah yeah
but then you got into fights and there
was a lot of racial tension it was the
90s
and bikes were stolen and we got robbed
all the time we had this crazy alarm
going off because our house was so big
and you would just i'd be like an
eight-year-old kid and you just hear
like
glass breaking and then i'm just like
i'm in my room like hugging up teddy
you know hoping i don't get raped by
[ __ ] leroy and uh
you know you go downstairs and hey the
tv's gone today you know and that was
that was a tuesday
yeah and we got robbed all the time my
dad he's got like he's like n word rich
you know where he's like oh we're gonna
buy a shitty lexus but it's alexis
you know so the lexus would get stolen
he's like all right he'll give me like
cab money to go to school and [ __ ]
and uh and that was just how it was i
remember i told this story on rogan but
i got my
bike stolen just just street tuffs you
know they would rub their front tire on
your back tire and that meant like uh
you're [ __ ]
and they would just take your bike
forever i didn't get a good night's
sleep but that [ __ ] did end up working
oh really
it worked for both of them yeah it
didn't work for me i tried these
dehydration pills
like to dry you out that didn't work and
then my dad eventually got so fed up
because
he was annoyed with the bed wetting he's
like you gotta grow up you [ __ ] loser
so he said no more liquids after six so
i'm sitting there eating doritos
at 608 going like you know i look like a
like a somali pirate i'm so thirsty
i'm like it's like water world i gotta
pee in a jar and filter it you know i'm
so thirsty and
you know my brother's guzzling uh
kool-aid and [ __ ] and pepsi and i'm like
guys
he's not having that problem at all no
it was brutal man
it was a dry county and so you would
would you not go to sleepovers because
of it
i would go because i wanted to hang and
i wanted to you know be a part of
society i don't want to be like a weirdo
like
disabled guy like i can't go i have a
problem so i would just stay up all
night
and like it was like i was like in a
holocaust death camp i was like all
right i'll sleep in shifts you know
i could sleep for like 10 minutes here
and i'll wake up and i saw everything i
would just walk around my friend's
houses at like two in the morning
they're they're snoozing
and i'd go into the mom's panties and
you know watch some tv
and check the fridge i was like a weird
night owl nightcrawler guy
at like nine you know checking out porn
you know i'm going in and out of the
house playing with a cat
whatever i had to do jerk off on a
friend's face anything just
anything kill the time did you guys jerk
off together you and your buds
no what never oh that was a big one that
was
yeah none of the what okay so let's talk
about that too because
was it a circle jerk thing or what was
it what it was
you're like nah come on
you take a corner i'll take a corner we
got the porn in the middle and uh
yeah it was like a bonding experience i
did make my friend taste it once and he
never talked to me again
is that real oh my his or yours his his
i was like i dare you to taste he's like
i'm not tasting i was like a double dog
and he was like ah
i hate you you know it was a great
moment he's never talking
i mean we're still cool he's uh he's
dead now he was a gay porn star
but uh alpha yeah he wins he wins yeah
yeah we're in new york it's it feels
more like oh that was a
clever take on that joke and it was it
feels more
arty a little bit like a little more
intellectually like
like david tell us i mentioned he looks
like a hobo right but he's this
brilliant guy
you know he's a le yeah yeah you always
have somebody like that
in the building that makes you check
that checks to all the levels yes
it's like even if he's not personally
doing it it's just him being there
right there's a ceiling as to what's
going on yeah but then you go to the
comedy store and i'm in the main room
green room and you're like look at all
these sexy dudes you know like brendan
schaub's a [ __ ]
chiseled fat [ __ ] like he's got the
slick hair
the cool shoes got a chain on i'm like i
would never even think to put on a chain
oh he's a white part of bacon yeah i
always call him the white part of bacon
still good but damn boy yeah yeah a
little thick and not good for you yeah
he's a thick crust
and he's got the cheese in there too oh
yeah you know you stretch it and it
pulls
but yeah it's like dang how much cheese
i know
i know but he's like seven foot one he's
got a huge piece and a bad ass that's
crazy one leg dude his other it's a it's
a [ __ ] penis with a neon
wow he's got a bendy dick he's got
ligaments
oh dude yeah he can stand on his dick
yeah that's pretty crazy it's a
kickstand a dick stand come see me live
uh before i kill myself so uh please
say you can say you saw me when
see me before i go full gay come on in
people sorry about the sunglasses i'm
culturally appropriating a jazz musician
there we go there you go
ah the lights
you